how hard was it to get the part on
Gray's Anatomy as you're uh coming up I
mean that's tough multiple auditions the
whole thing right did you know when you
got that that show was going to be huge
no no idea nobody knows no idea because
you know those shows that get on network
TV you never know you never know yeah
you just take the job yeah and you hope
and you cross your fingers and then you
wait to hear if the Pilot's gonna get
picked up okay they picked up the pilot
now how many are we gonna get to do and
then we had filmed I want to say we
filmed Nine episodes before they even
aired one and we were all kind of like
oh my God are they gonna not even air
this are they gonna scrap the whole idea
even though they put all this money into
making these episodes we had no idea
what was going to happen and when it
goes on the air it's pretty much an
instantaneous hit right it was yeah it
was right like it didn't have a build
and a network television now you gotta
hit right away yeah it's tough and so
you do in your first season do you get
the Emmy or how many seasons uh I want
to say the third season third season you
get nominated for an Emmy yeah and you
win it yeah was that a big deal or you
don't care it is no that's a big deal is
it a game changer I still look at that I
mean every morning when I get up I'm
like wow that happened and do people
treat you differently on set when you
win the Emmy no not really
no no they're like good job okay get
back to work did you prepare a speech or
did you think there's no way no I really
thought there was no way I was going to
win it um so when they call your name
you have no idea what you're going to
say no I said oh and they had to
like bleep it and I was like oh sorry
network television and then um I kind of
had to just get up I was so excited I
was just so mind blown
um
but you're you're like very outspoken in
the sense that like um then when you
were nominated for another Emmy you said
I'm taking my name out of Emmy
consideration I wish no isn't that true
no no no I wasn't nominated
um you didn't like one of the seasons
you didn't think that I wasn't feeling
good about my work that season no and
what you have to do for as an actor if
you want to you know get nominated you
have to submit your work right so you
kind of go through your season of work
and find stuff that you feel is worthy
of submission then you submit it than
they consider and they decide like who
they're going to nominate and who
they're not and that year you said don't
submit me I said I'm not going to submit
I can't find anything it's very
honorable good about you didn't feel
good about the writing or you didn't
feel good about your performance I
didn't feel good about my performance
and I didn't feel there was a part of me
that thought because I had won the year
before that I needed juicy dramatic
emotional material and I just didn't
have that that season why didn't they
give that to you I'm here you won the
Emmy you're clearly a draw on the show
why didn't they sit down and say now
let's get first something really I mean
since she's being so uh you know
heralded for her acting do you why do
you think people were against you there
that they should have said hey let's put
her in her place I think so I don't
think so I hope not there were I want to
say like 12 series regulars on that show
and everybody deserved their juicy
dramatic emotional season you know and
you cannot there's just I as a right I'm
not a writer but I imagine it must be
very difficult to do that for everybody
there's just too many people on that
show yeah there are a lot of people it's
a big show it's a big show right and
that's I think you know what made it
work so much too is because you've got
so many interesting characters and story
lines and I don't know how they kept all
that straight
thank you